احد المرات كنت طالعه بتاكسي سائق اللي
انا لو محلك بقوس حالي قلت له اول حاله
بكل بساطه وكثير المواقف بتتعدى الاشخاص
بيفكرونا نحن بحاجه مصاري لما نكون ماشيين
بالطريق بحاجه مساعدات باستخدموا هيك لا
في زاويه تانيه صح لازم نشوفها كانت
والدتي هي اللي تدعمني وتشجعني اني اطلع
وكملوا ادرس فبعدين وعرفتي توفت فجاه فكان
عندي خيارين يا اما انا اقعد بالبيت يا
اما اطلع واكمل فانا طلعت وكملت بعد
وفاتها بكم سنه طلعت معي فكره مبادره
الاعاقه انطلاقه لانه يمكن نحن في اشخاص
ما في حدا عم بيدعمهم فعلا قاعدين بالبيت
فكانت هاي الفكره وهذه الهدف منها
[موسيقى]
حاله هو صار له اربع سنين ببيته تاركه
دراسه وما بيعمل شي بسبب خطا طبي صار معه
انجاز ما كان انه احنا طلعناه لهذا الشخص
من البيت جرس وفاه الجامعه حياتو
كلياتهنقلت يعني انجاز عملنا نحن وظفنا
كتير اشخاص عن طريقنا ودربناهم وفوتناهم
لسوق العمل بالاضافه لنشاطات مع جهات
كثيره نحن محتضرين من مؤسسه اداره الموارد
البشريه من انطلاقنا وحاليا صرنا تحت ظل
وزاره الشؤون الاجتماعيه والعمل نحن حاليا
الفكره صارت تتغير يعني حتى الوزاره حتى
المسؤولين الجهات المعنيه صاروا يشوفونها
صح من الزاويه لان اصحاب الامام قادرين
يكونوا موجودين ففي دعم كثير كبير
[موسيقى]
انا هدفي اني اوصل للعالم الاشخاص من
اصحاب الامام قادرين يوصلوا تحت اي ظرف
ومثل ما خبرتك من شوي اصعب شيء عليه
الانسان هو فقدانه والدته فالانسان بيقدر
فكيف اذا كان فائدته هو من اصحاب الهمه
فما في شيء مستحيل بالنهايه بس بدها شويه
بدي اقول لها خليكي مثل ما انت ولا
تستسلمي تحت اي ظروف صح يعني انا اوقات
كثير بنهار كثير وصل لمرحله انه خلص ما
عاد بدي شي بس بعدين بقول لا ما في داعي
فبقول لها تطولي بالك واكيد في شي منيح
كتير